we are here today to celebrate the
marriage of Jake Peralta and Amy
Santiago I've known you both for the
last 5 years and it has been a true
pleasure to watch your distracting
childish rivalry evolve into a
distracting childish courtship and now
into what I'm sure will be a distracting
childish
marriage I'm proud of you and I love you
both permission to say it back
permission granted love you to Sir love
you
captain
is this seat
taken you really got to do this D my
name is Rachel Weinstein I'm a graduate
student on sabatical to study birds at
the University of Buenos Iris you know
Cornell has a far better Ornithology
department and it's right here in New
York Cornell has accused me of robbing a
bank and is going to send me to jail for
15 years I guess we're dropping the
metaphor I don't know why you're here
you're not going to change my mind I
know
I just wanted to say goodbye okay
goodbye I hope you know your family's
going to miss you I don't care I really
speak to them I was talking about the
99 be's safe Rachel
[Music]
Weinstein she's worried about her
motorcycle sitting Idol so she wants us
to take it out once a day here I think
you should do this you're more the biker
type I've seen you use a toothpick in
public motorcycles are death machines I
have three kids I'm not risking it are
you saying my life matters less because
I don't conform to society's
heteronormative child Centric ideals are
you really playing the gay card right
now go
Queen all right we got to get there
quick maybe we should take the
chopper use that Chopper death blade
Sidewinder it's go time Roger that wet
blanket no from now on call
me
velvet
Thunder okay what's going on here what
are you doing Captain hey nothing just
eating some marshmallows care for one
marshmallow I knew it treat her gently
you know that's not a nice car right say
that again damn cat be cool say that
again that's what I
thought I'll be in the
venue guess you should be very proud of
yourself I know things aren't exactly
way you want to be right now but uh I
promise you they will approve thank you
Captain every time someone steps up and
says who they are the world becomes a
better more interesting place
so thank
you well I wish you'd said something
before I spent all day making it of
course you didn't want to burst my
bubble pun intended and then you
did
so nice of you to greet us meline I
thought surely you'd still be crushed
under that house in Munchkin land Sticks
and Stones Raymond describing your
breakfast are you sure you wouldn't like
some help with this oh no need now for
my first tweet I think I should give an
update on the water main break that's
actually informative NYC H2O dmain sitre
colon at 2040 EDT current PSI 456 Max
cap 20400
LPM suck on that tasty lemon drop Olivia
Crawford oh look at that an alert I'm
probably trending already what my
account has been deactivated Twitter
thinks you're a bot why I'm a human I'm
a human male how dare you disobey me
come on sir it was a good tip and we're
trying to catch a serial killer well
then let's see this tip this
groundbreaking tip that threatens to
blow the case wide open okay I know this
tone Here Comes Petty halt n I'm
not being petty you just said n
show me the tip this is the boat now
Charles has to think we're totally sober
and we solved his puzzle so we good yep
I'm drunk as hell that's now what I ask
don't worry about me I've seen you do
enough of these hair brain schemes in
order to play along if Charles asks
what's wrong I'll just put on a qu smile
and
say nothing amazing that is actually
perfect okay we have a few more
questions for you doctor doctor huh it's
funny when people call dentist Doctor we
are doctors we do four years of medical
school no it's called dental school but
we learned about the entire body yeah
but if you had cancer you would call it
dentist you know it's actually harder to
get into dental school than medical
school what because there are fewer
dental schools because most people want
to become actual doctors that's
ridiculous it's not like we're College
professors calling ourselves doctors
that's the same thing my friend well
sure it is when someone has a heart
attack on a plane do they yell out yo
does anybody here have an art history
PhD a PhD is a doctored is literally
describing a doctor maybe let's refocus
no the problem here is that medical
practitioners have co-opted the word
doctor okay captain now I know we live
in a world where anything can mean
anything and nobody even cares about
etom apparently that's a trigger for me
yeah oh I see you have a knife but what
you need is an umbrella tell them why
tell them why cuz there's a storm going
to rain down on you punk and if I'm not
ready with a guy as great as Marcus
then what if I'm never ready what if
that was it my one chance of
love what if I never get a second
chance I don't
know I'm
just I'm just
sad I I
understand it must be very
difficult wait are you crying
yes thank you for acknowledging my
feelings thank you for acknowledging
M we're both great at
this on my first day here I asked
Jeffers to tell me about everyone told
me you were a great detective but the
one thing you couldn't figure out was
how to grow
up
well I think you finally figured it
out well thank you sir I couldn't have
done it without you over the years
you've sometimes referred to me as
something of a the figure did I I didn't
realize that but I want you to know if I
had had a son and uh he had turned out
like
you I would be very proud of
him thank you
sir wasn't expecting to get this
emotional it's not bad for an old robot
huh s
sir did you just make a joke I believe I
did yes I guess in the end we rubbed off
on each other quite a
bit title of your sex
movie did I do that right it was
perfect I want to say it has been a
pleasure to have worked alongside all of
you for the past 21 and A2 months I'm
sorry for getting so emotional pretty
consistent tone actually these have been
the these have been the best years of my
career oh no this is new and I know that
every one of
you give me everything you
hand and I will never forget it go back
to being robot
Captain me more
see
dismissed